this is what you dream about this is
what we've been waiting for it's pent up
emotion it's an appreciation and love
for baseball coming from the fans of the
field and i'll guarantee you it's going
to be coming from the field back to the
fans
maria's 9-2 with an era of 3.56
making his 14th start of the year one of
the most highly touted left-handers
uh in like dodgers history he's one of
those guys that they thought was going
to be the next fernando valenzuela i
really do believe that's one of the
reasons why he really struggles at home
because of the expectations you're just
so high
and the 24 year old left-hander back
home with a slur that sliced to
left-center field bets on the move he
calls off baby and makes a running catch
for the first down of the night that's
had a long way to go it was slicing away
from him off the left-handed hitting oh
double herrera one gone in this first
inning and here is one of the hottest
hitters in the national league jean
segura 335 overall and 388 over his last
12 games seguro to be followed by j.t
romuto and he lines that one into center
field of base hit
so gene's aboard and he's taking a huge
turn around first
and then goes back
the 2-2 is a ground ball to short lux to
taylor on to first
real muto among his other skills he runs
especially well
and his speed kept it from being a
double play
there's two out so gets harper to the
plate here in the first inning there
goes the runner
on a fly ball lofted to the left from
matt beatty
julio urias for the one two three first
facing zach f1 who's owen three lifetime
against the dodgers with an era of 9.53
but i think this is a different zac f1
than the one who
faced the dodgers previously and the 2-2
pitch on the way
strike called over the outside corner
betts shaking his head he did not like
the call didn't miss off the edge but it
was close enough for him to call it sir
one away here in the bottom of the first
that'll bring up gavin lux
bouncing ball up the middle backhand
williams across his body not in time
infield single gavin right
through space runner with the game and
here's turner uh 3-2 coming there goes
lox turner yanks it over short basic
left field and lux will advance to third
dodgers making some things happen
putting the runner in motion with a full
count pitch
justin turner is one of the better two
strike hitters and he does just that for
his manager tonight's cleanup man will
smith stands in two home runs in his
last three games he had two home runs
over his previous 31 on a 2-1 pitch
it's a bouncing ball softly to shore
williams goes to second one
is late and the dodgers lead one nothing
so smith will get an rbi on the feeders
choice ground out breaking ball away
tops it and tops it just slow enough to
beat it out here's mccutchen and the
pitch to catch swung on hit high and
deep left field it's way back and baity
looks up he's out of room it is gone and
andrew mccutchen first ball swinging
sends one out to straight away left it's
his 11th home run of the season and the
phillies have tied it up it's a 1-1 game
oh what a great swing right here and
that's exactly what the phillies need to
do they need to hunt the fastball and
that's exactly what kutch did right here
fastball down and in just a little bit
and he absolutely crushed it he knew it
a draw the rock paper scissors tonight
but segura comes up empty back-to-back
caves to open this third
change up flared off the end of the bat
on comes mckenzie to make a diving play
zach mckenstry take a bow in front of a
packed house in dodger stadium gold
glove play marias has given up one in
the mccutcheon home run here he is in
the fourth ready to face the heart of
the lineup
slurve to finish them all
that's where the combination of the two
pitches let you get away with a little
weaker spray pattern on the breaking
ball this one doesn't have the complete
finish but because of the high fastball
before that was executed so perfectly
the breaking ball has a little bigger
window for success well bryce harper is
out of this ball game bryce uh looking
upset this is his first plate appearance
and this is what we're talking about
that something was bothering him it
looked like maybe his midsection is
groin or something like that he kind of
pulled off that pitch a little bit and
it didn't look like he was real
comfortable right there after that pitch
now mckinstry is single to left in his
first stat back another one-two
mckinstry it's a fly ball to right
center field towards the gap that'll
split it
it's cut off by herrera taylor on his
horse rounding third relay to the play
bounces over
go ahead double zack mckinstry 2-1
dodgers in the fourth
now
grounded out to short his first time but
has driven in seven in his last four
starts
[Applause]
oh yeah
bounces into the seats he's done it
again
3-1 dodgers bottom part of the order
doing it getting the job done when
you're locked in and you get the bat on
plane you barrel them up and that's
where hulu is right now he might only
get the hit every fifth day but when he
gets his chance up there he has been
doing some damage
over two with a fly ball to center in a
strikeout well now base head should
score two o2 pitch
and o'doodle shoots it the other way
that's in for a base hit one is in
williams will be hard to third it's
kicked around and now williams will come
home bait he misplayed it the phillies
have tied it up at three and just a pure
chase pitch away maybe a full body
length way off the plate on this curve
ball top of the order for the dodgers
with mookie bets leading it off the o2
a fly ball to left center field this
one's got a chance and it is gone
bets his eighth home run of the year has
given the dodgers a four to three lead
this crowd is going apoplectic and lucky
has a moment in his first game at a
sold-out dodger stadium a tie-breaking
home run here in the seventh i think
that was a mookie jersey yes it was
tied at second go ahead run it first 2-2
to alec baum
fastball bullseye back to their case and
two out
a strikeout swinging and a strikeout
looking and so after the back-to-back
walks to start the inning back-to-back
strikeouts and one local guy facing
another with the game on the line in the
eighth inning
chopper to third for turner takes it to
the bag and bickford's out of the jam
something about more people that helps
you go next level with your
concentration i wonder if it's going to
help mookie on this 2-1
he hits one through the motor base at
center field milky bats owning center
stage tonight
the dodgers with big insurance late at
5-3
crime and set
the pitch
strike three
that will end the game no matter how it
finished it finished and it's a 5-3 win
for the dodgers here on reopening day